- May the best bitch win.
(dance beat)
- I'm here repping the
queen of rap, Nicki Minaj.
- I'm here repping the one
and only multi-talented
Mariah Carey.
- I'm here repping Mother
Monster, Lady Gaga.
- And I'm here repping
the Beehive Baby, Beyonce.
I just fee like Beyonce is
the only one that does have
a look. Gaga is like super manufactured,
I mean, just throw some meat on it, honey.
The only thing that Mariah
ever had as a good outfit
was a butterfly top in the early 2000s,
and then what happened?
Eden's crush wore it, and it was done.
As far as Nicki, Nicki
was like a bootleg Gaga,
like she should go sit down.
So the Queen Bee has continued to slay.
I mean, she was who you
were talking about at like
the Met Gala.
Were y'all even invited? (laughing)
- Mariah's always dressed
for the gods, honey.
Gowns, flawless hair, makeup on point.
(interrupting)
Shh.
- Let me just, okay, let me,
- Yeah, what's going on with
your look, Lady Gaga? (laughter)
- Woah, okay, all of those
outfits, they mean something
to her. She dressed in that steak
because she was talking - Crazy.
about equality, and saying
that it was the prime rib.
Sure it's a crazy message, but
it got people to look at her,
and that's what she's using her fame for.
- Okay, my turn. - Ain't nobody
care about what you wearing.
- Still irrelevant, nobody cares.
- The most like defining characteristic
of Nicki Minaj's look
is and always has been
dat ass though.
And like that was what
the whole Anaconda thing
revolved around.
- Is that classy, though?
Should she cover up her booty?
- No.
- Oh, I clearly win that. Hello.
- Miley, what's good? Miley, what's good?
Miley, what's good?
- Oh, Jesus. Ratchet.
- Like isn't it problematic
that like we called Nicki
ratchet, anyways?
'Cause like by that we just mean,
"Oh, she's not like a white
fancy artist that wears gowns."
- I think Mariah's
ratchet behind the scenes.
Like, she doesn't give
you ratchet in your face.
- That is not a bad thing.
I'll have a little ratchet
every Friday night.
- Oh, well fuck. I wrote
the book on ratchetness.
- I seen her over the
weekends, I know she is.
- Yeah, I'm gonna say Mariah's
probably like the most
like attitudal diva out there.
- I feel like Beyonce
and Mariah are like icons
at this point.
Gaga's crawling, working her way up there.
- Crawling?
- The thing about Nicki's diva attitude
is that she busts it out for
the sake of saying something
that matters.
She took a big hit when she
called out Miley like that.
Everyone was like, "Who is
this savage, ratchet-ass black
woman that's hacking this like
pretty little white girl?"
- I know, right. I'm like, "Oh."
- It's true.
- Right? It's like, people
said that about her, and like,
okay, yeah, she's got
an attitude, and yeah,
she tore her to pieces,
but for a good reason.
- Mariah is the epitome
of talent, dahling.
18 number ones, countless awards.
- Remember Glitter?
- Countless awards.
- Yeah, remember Glitter?
- Anyone's out-of-date at this one.
(shrieks)
- Are you a dungeon dragon?
(laughter)
- Nicki Minaj is the queen of rap.
Last year at the BET Awards,
she was given Artist of the Year Award,
she threw some mad shade at Iggy.
- It seems like she's always
throwing shade at people.
Throwing mad shade.
- 'Cause there's a lot of
dumbass culturally-appropriating
white girls running around.
- So Lady Gaga writes her own songs,
she designs her own shows,
she used to design all
of her own costumes.
- Beyonce is just the most
talented being on the planet.
She rocked the Super Bowl
without any sort of props,
she didn't have little dancing sharks,
or little beach balls, Miss Katy Perry.
She didn't need other like Death Stars.
- Cali and Michelle.
I mean, Michelle kinda failed, but,
- You mean her backup dancers came?
No, I don't get drunk
and watch fucking like
The Sound of Music.
I get drunk and I wanna see Beyonce.
- Our divas wouldn't want us fighting.
- We would collaborate with each other.
- I will say that I do listen
to each and every single one
of these girls on my Spotify.
- Yeah, I listen to them.
- They all good icons.